bonjour jean christophe cambadélis cbi
un bon show merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
a représenté aujourd'hui par le journal
ouest france avec vous stéphane bern et
à directeur de la rédaction parisienne
de west de ouest france bonjour stéphane
bonjour bonjour jean christophe
cambadélis on va bien sûr parler de la
gauche du parti socialiste de la nuque
mais avant cela l'actualité du jour
c'est la journée de mobilisation de
l'hôpital avec partout en france et bien
ces syndicats et collectifs de soignants
qui appelle et bien à des mesures pour
faire face à l'urgence pour l'hôpital
avec la fermeture de beaucoup de
services d'urgence dans le territoire
d'abord un mot sur un constat c'est une
situation dramatique et est ce que le
gouvernement il répond d'un constat amer
parce que ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'on se penche sur l'avenir de
l'hôpital
on a même mois il ya moins d'un an
u11 ségur sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
et suite à la coved et on s'en sort pas
s'en sort pas parce que d'un côté la
revendication principale et salariales
et de l'autre côté l'impensé principal
du gouvernement est la question des lits
mais on ne touche pas le problème de
fond problème de fond c'est repenser
l'hôpital en lui même est dans la ville
si on ne met pas ces deux paramètres on
n'y arrivera jamais c'est repenser la
prise en charge
repenser les questions administratives
repenser la formation et l'information
de l'école de rennes en particulier
parce que c'est c'est pas la première
fois que l'on traite du sujet je crois
que la première fois qu'on a dû traiter
le sujet d'une manière globale c'est en
1989 1988
et ça ne s'est pas améliorée pourquoi
pas parce qu'on n'a pas voulu repenser
ses trois grands piliers qui sont
nécessaires à son redémarrage de
l'hôpital indépendamment des efforts
faits par les personnels dans ces lieux
dans le ségur de la santé il n'y a pas
que des augmentations de salaires ils
ont assurément très gros volet
d'investissements et ce volet
investissement il ne touche pas au point
que vous venez d'évoquer absolue à
réorganiser nos choix ne touche pas du
tout ils ne touchent pas il y a eu les
bâtiments en fait c'est même pas oui
voilà c'est pas ce qui est déjà pas mal
il faut quand même le jeu nécessaire
noter c'est nécessaire mais
c'est plus globalement un problème parce
qu'on pourrait se projeter sur
l'éducation nationale c'est exactement
la même chose c'est à dire que
on veut modifier les choses sans
s'attaquer réellement aux problèmes dans
le détail et c'est un angle d'attaqué
voit très bien à chaque fois la question
et budgétaire donc le gouvernement dit
mais moi j'ai pas les moyens de mettre
de déverser début des centaines de
milliards pour tout refaire donc c'est
très difficile
et on voit bien que de l'autre côté
pas suffisamment de personnel pas
suffisamment payés avec des tâches qui
sont de plus en plus lourdes sur le plan
administrative le découragement
la surcharge on le sait que c'est que
l'urgence et le boulot d'étranglement
des hôpitaux aujourd'hui que comme n'y a
pas de messie de ville je prenais un
exemple je me coupe le lam un bon cinq
points de suture et s'est achevée aux
médecins de ville qui va me fait les
points de suture je vais directement le
pit algérie avec monde avec ma main
ensanglantée comme ça bon on prend tout
de suite et on le fait dans plus bon
vois mon cambadélis donc on prend en
charge assez rapidement mais
ccc la situation lâcher c'est mon
exemple personnel mais c'est la
situation pour tous tout le monde va
directement à l'hôpital donc il ya un
problème de la plus de la prise en
charge et il y aurait une nécessité de
faire un tri d'avoir un double processus
ceux qui sont dans l'urgence urgence et
ceux qui sont dans une urgence
secondaire je sais je sais les termes ne
sont pas pour obligatoirement juste mais
on voit bien que il ya là une difficulté
majeure emmanuel macron lance mission
d'information flash dans moi pour
justement bien faire le constat des
besoins dans le territoire c'est
nécessaire
il démine il démine parce que il ya
urgence parce que c'est au bord de
l'explosion et parce qu'on est dans une
période électorale mais il ne pense pas
je crois toujours moi j'espère qu'ils ne
pensent pas tu avec cette mission flash
on va régler les problèmes s'est montré
qu'il y a un intérêt de la part de du
gouvernement sur le sujet c'est pas un
peu maladroit parce que ça fait quand
même des années qu'on parle du problème
voulait très bien de le dire le ségur
c'est des négociations qui ont duré tout
l'été où tout a été posée est ce que est
ce que enfin l'idée ce serait de réussir
à faire quoi de plus en un mois ça vous
répondez à la question que tifs étaient
posées rien de plus il s'agit de montrer
une attention de dire que on s'en occupe
que c'est une préoccupation qu'on ne
laisse pas de côté parce que aujourd'hui
la question de la santé touche
l'ensemble des français nous sortons de
l'aco vide et il est évident que la
question de la santé la question de la
sécurité et la question des salaires
sont les trois piliers des
interrogations des frustrations des
interpellations de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens à jean christophe cambadélis
on va évoquer les premiers textes de ce
nouveau quinquennat d'emmanuel macro et
notamment sa méthode il prône une
méthode nouvelle avec la création d'un
conseil national de la refondation qui
baptise ses nerfs en hommage en
référence au conseil national de la
résistance alors là en 2022 c'est un
conseil qui réunit les forces politiques
économiques sociales et des citoyens
tirés au sort pour donner un avis
réfléchir aux réformes du quinquennat
c'est une bonne idée ou c'est de la
communication
ça pourrait être une bonne idée si c'est
déboucher par sur des propositions qui
soient reprises par le président de la
république mais on a l'expérience sur la
question climatique ou
les prises de position
n'ont pas été
reprises par les présidents de la
république
moi je crois que le présent la
république constate comme tout le monde
qu'il y ait un blocage dans notre
société que le verticalisme fait des
dégâts énormes à tous les niveaux
tilly a une envie de de participation
des citoyens et de déconcentration
décentralisation de l'ensemble des
collectivités locales donc ils essayent
de répondre à cette question
en proposant ce conseil national de la
réforme mais je suis très sceptique
quant à sa
capacité à prendre en compte ce qui sera
dit ou
dégager un danser dans ces débats et
pourquoi est ce qu'il est obligé ou
pourquoi est ce qu'ils proposent ce cnr
pour reprendre le terme ce conseil
national de l'arête de la refondation
pourquoi pourquoi ce qui a obligé de
proposer ce type d'outil si ce n'est
parce que les corps intermédiaires sont
très faibles normalement par exemple la
réforme des retraites ça devrait se
négocier entre les syndicats et les
pouvoirs publics or si on ne fait plus
est ce que c'est pas aussi parce que les
syndicats sont particulièrement faibles
dans deux pays aujourd'hui les syndicats
sont faibles mais on les aide pas être
fort
c'est évident qu'ils sont faibles par
rapport par exemple à l'allemagne
exactement au même à l'angleterre en
deux sous une autre sous une autre forme
mais
si vous ne n'ouvrez pas des négociations
avec les organisations syndicales
si vous n'êtes pas dans la capacité de
d'engager le dialogue social voulait
minorée et si vous créez des bidules on
va dire pour parler comme le général de
gaulle dans lequel les syndicats sont
noyés vous les marginaliser non il faut
ouvrir des négociations sérieuses
il faut aussi avoir un constat qui est
un constat commun et donc c'est tout
cela se prépare
mais je pense que d'un côté la tendance
de nos gouvernants c'est pas la première
fois mais la tendance de nos gouvernants
et le centralisme et le jacobinisme et
l'a10 et la décision administrative qui
vient d'en haut et la tendance des
organisations syndicales a parlé
réformisme et d'une manière générale
c'est la négation de la proposition
c'est à dire qu'on ne fait pas de
proposition et emmanuel macron a
beaucoup plus court circuiter les corps
intermédiaires que ces prix bien sûr
parce que c'est en partie responsable de
ça envoie il s'était très clair dans son
premier livre qui était révolution
l'idée qui était une idée qui avait déjà
développé françois hollande d'ailleurs
qui était que le problème français
c'était la lenteur administrative et la
lenteur de la décision politique c'est à
dire quand vous avez un problème la
décision politique dans son effectué
alité c'est à dire dont cinq donnant
dans son quand elle arrive chez le
citoyen elle met un an et demi deux ans
et qu'il fallait aller plus vite sa
réponse la réponse du président de la
république emmanuel macron c'est
en court circuite les corps
intermédiaires qui nous font perdre du
temps mais au fur et à mesure de la vie
politique
il s'est rendu compte que les corps
intermédiaires
c'était peut-être ce qui fait
fonctionner aujourd'hui amortisseurs
osant voilà bon et donc il a cherché à
réintégrer les corps intermédiaires dans
l'action
gouvernementale sans pour autant perdre
la centralité et la décision d'autant
plus qu' il aime pas trop partager le
débat politique alors dans ce début de
quinquennat il ya une réforme qui va
faire l'objet d'une concertation avec
les syndicats c'est la réforme des
retraites emmanuel macron là dit elle
entrera en vigueur à l'été 2000 23 jean
christophe cambadélis quelle est votre
ligne sur cette réforme des retraites
est ce qu'il faut
augmenter repousser l'âge de départ ou
comme le propose emmanuel macron luis
qu'il faut revenir à la retraite à 60
ans comme le progrès jean luc mélenchon
est bien dit lundi l'autre je suis moi
sur la position de la cfdt c'est à dire
que on a déjà fait d'eux des efforts
considérables
aujourd'hui on peut jouer sur les
trimestres mais c'est le maximum que
l'on puisse faire et je ne pense pas
contrairement à ce que beaucoup disent
que ce soit l'urgence du moment et
d'ailleurs je vois que dans les
recommandations
du président de la république à madame
elisabeth bornes premier ministre la
question des retraites a disparu il ya
pas il n'y a pas d'appel il n'y a pas
les retraites donc on voit bien du
chiffon rouge on veux pas agiter sa
moment des élections législatives et
sans reprendre ce qu'a dit xavier
bertrand mais il ya quand même l'idée
que d'un agenda tâches et c'est à dire
pour fera ça plus tard et on verra
autrement mais il ya une idée qui fait
son chemin c'est que l'urgence française
et est plutôt sur la santé sur les
salaires et sur la sécurité et peut-être
pas autant que l' on le dit sur la
question des règles dans la dans
l'interview que le président république
accordait la presse régionale vendredi
dernier il dit quand même qui veut que
le cette réforme des retraites entre en
vigueur dès l'été 2023 il ne peut pas
être il peut pas être parjures je dirais
par rapport à ce qu'il a dit lors des
élections
présidentielles mais on voit bien que ce
n'est pas
s'est-elle c'était la principale
proposition du programme présidentiel et
c'est celle aussi qui fait beaucoup plus
beaucoup de débats et voilà la crise pas
super mais elle avait pour elle avait
pour but peut-être de régler le problème
des retraites encore que je suis
sceptique mais elle avait pour but de
donner identité
au président de la république dans la
présidentielle une identité qui soit
compatible avec
une majorité de droite on va dire là
aujourd'hui président de la république
est confronté à une montée entre
guillemets de la gauche et comme c'est
quelqu'un qui est réactif il fait
attention à ce qu'il dit justement
parlez en deux bien c'est un enjeu des
élections législatives et notamment de
la nuque de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale avec d'abord des
premiers résultats de ces élections pour
les français de l'étranger et peut-être
une surprise en tout cas un événement la
défaite de l'ancien premier ministre
socialiste manuel valls éliminée dès le
premier tour est ce que manuel valls ont
encore un avenir politique jean
christophe cambadélis ce c'est à lui de
le dire j'ai vu qu'il avait quitté
twitter ce qui était quand même une une
indignation qui ne veut plus être en
phase avec le combat politique quotidien
que induit twitter la question qu'on se
pose c'est qu'est-ce qu'il a été faire
dans cette galère qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient parce que bon pouvaient être
candidats aux élections législatives
mais pourquoi aller dans les cieux les
français de l'étranger pourquoi aller
dans un territoire où il y avait un
début d'un député elle et aurait même si
visiblement voulait se maintenir c'était
et c'est au second tour et les kits au
second tour mais c'était la
démonstration que la division de la
majorité à les conduire à ce que la
gauche serait en position et il y avait
très peu de chances pour que manuel
valls ce soit au deuxième tour bon voilà
je les observe aussi que sa défaite a
provoqué sur les réseaux sociaux
énormément de de réaction positive et
non pas négative donc pour revenir c'est
pas facile vous vous sentez qu'elle est
en train de se réveiller c'est la
campagne pour les législatives quitter
totalement atone en attendaient à une
semaine du premier tour enfin moins
d'une semaine du premier tour il se
passe quelque chose où c'est toujours
aussi fun grand plat cc encéphalogramme
plat mais vous savez ce que disent les
sondeurs c'est que les majorité de
français se déterminent dans la dernière
semaine bond de plus en plus tard de
plus en plus tard alors donc on a ce
phénomène un peu bizarre où les camps
ben ils sont extrêmement londres on
commence très très très très tôt cette
semaine entre la présidentielle et le
deuil voilà on commence très tôt la
présidentielle a commencé très tôt
législatives ont commencé très tôt mais
on se précipite très tard et on accélère
très tard
aujourd'hui mais
je crains que le résultat de ces
élections législatives soient
l'abstentionnisme comme premier premier
parti pense comme marine le pen commencé
à dire là maintenant que finalement elle
voudrait où elle vise 100 à 150 sièges à
l'assemblée c'est on est dans la
communication politique à nouveau ou
pour sais que c'est possible
ça me semble extrêmement difficile parce
que savait le scrutin uninominal à deux
tours et périble ce n'est pas la
proportionnelle au premier tour on
choisit
et au deuxième tour on élimine
ceux qui donnent la situation suivante
la majorité a toujours un centre de
gravité extrêmement bas en dire le moins
possible pour pouvoir être jugé au
deuxième tour comme étant le les
candidats ou le candidat qui doit être
désigné face aux extrêmes et et le
président de la république a fait de
cette situation une théorie politique
c'est à dire le centre qui tient grâce
au refus des extrêmes
ce peut être extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'il ya plus de débat politique et on
en est là on en a la preuve aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut abaisser le débat
politique il faut être celui que l'on
choisit au deuxième tour c'est un peu la
stratégie de françois mitterrand
fermenté
c'était différent parce que françois
mitterrand s'appuyer sur une union de la
gauche qui était dynamique à l'époque
mais bon
cette théorie là d'ailleurs dans dans
l'interview donnée à la presse régionale
on le voit bien il le dit d'ailleurs il
le dit qu' il faut faire barrage à jean
luc mélenchon est un marine le pen donc
si je résume cette situation les
extrêmes font toujours de bons scores au
premier tour mais elles sont battus au
second et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ne fallait pas extrait mise et
l'union de la gauche il fallait la
rendre compatible avec
les tad de l'opinion et bien justement
justement parlons de cette union de la
gauche autour de jean-luc mélenchon la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale on se dirige peut-être vers de
nombreux duels au second tour entre la
majorité présidentielle et la nuque on
sait que vous êtes opposés à cette union
autour de jean luc mélenchon mais quelle
foi quelle position auriez-vous jean
christophe cambadélis dans ses duels
écoutez moi je suis un homme de gauche
mais dans les dans les conditions
actuelles je d'abord je dirais qu'il
faut voter pour les socialistes quelle
que soit l'heure kazakh si je peux dire
puisqu'il ya un 70
socialistes qui sont en compétition y
compris contre la nuque et puis il y à
des candidats socialistes
métissons
dans le cadre de la cause les
dissidences il ya deux mois je serai là
voté pour les 60% du dissident ce sont
là vos tombes en voilà et puis pour les
unes pour les autres socialistes parce
que je pense toujours à la suite et la
suite c'est que le la france a besoin
d'une gauche responsable et que l'on
peut et que je souhaite que l'on puisse
la reconstituer bon bref puis après moi
ce sera au cas par cas par cas au cas
par pas parce que je veux savoir quels
sont
les objectifs les orientations des
candidats et six essais en faisant un
peu de politique fiction et si jean luc
mélenchon réussit c'est son coup ci la
nuque avait avait une majorité à
l'assemblée qui devienne premier
ministre on va en parler mais est ce que
ça ne serait pas l'arrêt de mort du
parti socialiste un autre cas de
victoire c'est ce sera pas la victoire
de la nuque ce sera la victoire de jean
luc mélenchon et l'écrasera tout à
gauche mais il écrase déjà c'est à dire
que cet accord n'est pas gagnant on le
voit bien personne ne pense que jean luc
mélenchon peut-être lui j'en sais rien
mais personne ne pense que jean luc
mélenchon sera le prochain premier
ministre
donc la gauche réformiste écologiste a
perdu son âme
pour installer jean luc mélenchon qui va
être le leader moral politique la
référence de l'union de l'ensemble de la
gauche qui posera d'énormes problèmes
pour la suite mais si on prend votre
votre raisonnement
il faudrait voir si le programme de jean
luc mélenchon permet à la france de se
sortir de l'ensemble de ses difficultés
quand on entend ce qui vient de dire sur
la police un peu quelques doutes quand
même sur la capacité de jean luc
mélenchon team n'est pas dans une
perspective de gouverner
il est dans la perspective de la
perspective d' interpellé c'est un c'est
un leader qui interpellent les
responsables politiques peut-être pour
faire avancer les choses
mais en tout est calme en tout état de
cause pas pour gouverner pas pour
transformer par la loi et ça c'est la
limite quand il est confronté à un
problème entre deux solutions la
solution réformistes ou la solution
radicale et choisit toujours la solution
radicale alors vous en tout cas vous
souhaitez lancer un mouvement de
refondation de la gauche sociale
démocrate la gauche du gouvernement
comme vous l'appelez vous avez lancé un
manifeste social démocrate mais
plusieurs cadres du parti socialiste ont
eux aussi lancé leur initiative avec
notamment carole delga la présidente de
la région occitanie qui mènent ces
candidats dissidents socialistes et qui
veut faire les états généraux de la
gauche à la rentrée bernard cazeneuve
françois hollande ont également leur
propre campagne sur le terrain stéphane
le foll l'ancien ministre agriculture
pourquoi déjà ne pas se rassembler avant
de refonder la gauche sociale-démocrate
c'est pour cela que j'ai lancé le g1 et
lettres il a parlé sur j'ai écrit une
lettre ouverte à l'ensemble des
opposants à l'accord avec jean luc
mélenchon pour qu'il y ait une
coordination et ils vous avez
oublié dans les noms go citiez hélène
geoffroy qui est quand même celle qui
dirige la minorité du parti socialiste
et je crois que tout cela tout ce qui
est fait tout ce qui est proposé n'est
pas contradictoire à condition que ça
débouche sur une nouvelle formation
politique issue du parti socialiste je
l'espère mais si elle n'était pas si ça
n'était pas le parti socialiste une
nouvelle formation plus social démocrate
du gauche de gouvernement etc
et le premier objectif c'est de gagner
le prochain congrès après on verra ce
que l'on fait enfin mon avis est donc
celle des fournées olivier faur détrôner
olive force et une nouvelle orientation
c'est une réorientation c'est une
refondation pas simplement des tombes
faire en sorte que olivier faure ne soit
pas le prochain premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste mais de toute façon
nous savons tous
deux olivier faure dans quelques
semaines ou dans quelques mois rompre à
son accord avec jean-luc mélenchon parce
que pour gagner son congrès il sera
obligé de le faire
donc on voit que tout cela est à courte
vue mais entre temps on entend installer
jean luc mélenchon comme clé de voûte de
l'ensemble de la gauche non merci
beaucoup jean christophe cambadélis sa
mort était notre invité politique
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup stéphane
[Musique]